Hầu trân, tôi quyền nhỏ, là trên lớn khi COVID có dấu yệu chờ lại.
COVID mấy chiến đào có dấu yệu chờ lại,
một số việc tại hàng lỗi và tình phố hồ chỉ lấy đã khi nhận các cả những mời
phần lớn có chíu xin nhẹ.
Đăng truyến, xuất hiện cả trường rực tay nhận.
Trời thế vì vizu vẫn tổn tại trong cộng lồng và trưa thể chục quan.
Vy chương gung pháp tình là sống lớn,
hát chứ dạo quình cáo người dân đến chủ lọc phòng lợn.
Tặc viesong mỗi cạnh, dụng lời đã nơi lòng tình giáp,
các vị pháp phòng dịch các bạn vẫn cần được vý trị.
Bông hồn thường xây dựa gai bằng xa phòng hồn xin xanh quần.
Hàn sẽ thu tập nơi đồng người liệu không cần thiết.
Tâm bảo khúc xác sống phát làm việc được thông tháng.
Và đặc biệt, kêu khổ chăng đúng cách vẫn là nạn chẳng thúc quan nhất
tể hạch chỉ lấy lạn trong một trường cộng cộng,
thổ chăng đặt trình có khả năng lọc mỗi lịt và viên quần.
Tết thật thích kể thông tháng,
là nơi trọng được nhiều người yệu tiền, nhất là trong một nạn lắm.
Dịch bệnh có thể chương phát, nhưng ý trước phòng người liên bắt đầu từ những hình đồng nhỏ.
Đức hút cho quan đều khổ chăng không chỉ để bảo việc xác khỏe cán nhân.
Và có để xây dựa gai bằng một cộng đồng ăn toàn chù lòng trong mỗi tình buông.